[Music]
I'm Batman and I'm a big fan my question
to you is why isn't the agricultural
sector especially with the cows being
addressed with global warming with as
much media attention
as the oil companies see as it is
actually the biggest factor affecting
global warming at this day and age do
your ability to there's a conspiracy
Thank You Batman
thank you for your question I hardly
recognize you I really appreciate you
introducing yourself so there is
actually a lot of attention being drawn
to the effect of agriculture on climate
change and I want to emphasize it's
really cow belches coming out the mouth
where most of the methane comes from
they have four stomachs they do things a
little differently than we do and people
are studying ways to make cows less belt
full I don't know how effective they're
gonna be but there is actually a lot of
attention being drawn to it as far as
there being a conspiracy I really
wouldn't call it a conspiracy just call
we've been doing it this way for so long
200 years
burning fossil fuels burning the
material of ancient swamps or wetlands
that's a hard habit to break when it
comes to agriculture keep in mind that
there are 7.3 billion people around
today but by 2050 there will be at least
9 billion people there maybe 10 billion
people and so those people are gonna
have to eat and it's very reasonable
that all of us will move increasingly
toward a plant-based diet and it will
not be economical to raise cattle and
sell meat that it may go that way just
with market forces all this
side or all this included or think about
all this at once what would be great I
will say as a science educator a voter
and taxpayer what would be great is if
we had a tax oh we cannot ever use the
word tax if we had a fee on the
production of greenhouse gases so if you
have a dairy farm if you have a meat
ranch cattle ranch a pig farm or ranch a
fair owing operation what have you if
you if the farmer or the rancher were
required to add the cost of putting
methane in the atmosphere to the cost of
his or her products then consumers would
make different decisions about those
products and this fee would be
inherently fair we would have it on
agricultural products we would have it
on oil and gas used in transportation
we'd have it on the transportation that
the oil and gas used to take ships
across the ocean so it would be a fair
and inherent tariff on goods produced
overseas whether they are manufactured
goods or agricultural products this is a
big idea but when you have the fossil
fuel industry working so hard to
introduce doubt about climate change and
you have the climate change deniers who
have been so successful getting the idea
that doubt that plus or minus 2% is
really plus or minus a hundred percent
it's been very difficult to get this
sort of thing like a carbon fee or a
methane fee put in place so I'm
skeptical of a conspiracy but I am I
want you to know people are thinking
hard about the effects of Agriculture
and methane and meat production on the
environment but it's an excellent
question Batman an excellent question
now I know you're having fun but I
encourage you when you ask serious
questions maybe to not dress as Batman
with that said I think everybody here
had a good time with it so maybe you did
the right thing carry on Batman
carry on protect us all Caped Crusader
[Music]